[ __ ] au chômage aurait parlé club
j'aime bien et ça et c'est dans plein de
contacts ça marche ça marche quand tu es
vraiment énervé ça peut marcher dans un
moment coquin savent marcher way gilles
c'est quoi votre site préféré
je suis vraiment ou non calme et beau
fils de chekkal mois et demandait à être
calme ce lundi sur la fuite peut
préférer celle écrit pour wii s'étire
entre cinq ippons ça serait plutôt va
tenir cuire un oeuf malabar tout est
dans l'intention à l'âge et non la
tension et la question vous imaginez ils
sont venus en voiture avec un gars il
ouvre la vie tu vas pas te faire cuire
un oeuf malabar dirigeants brouille avec
quelqu'un ou pas oui et les récemment
non récemment dans le cadre d'une
séquence à des missions en prêt sinon et
avant jamais on ne m'a donné des coups
de poing je sais pas j'allais voir là la
cpe et l'aurait alors faut pas le faire
sa prière attention quoi c'est pas vrai
il n'est pas ma gueule et avait pas
génial c'est moche très moche à tous les
jeunes qui morgan ne le fait pas regardé
comme on nous l'a d'or au contraire
c'est le plus marrant du monde bon ça
dépend des heures et des jours 1o ont
majoré par les clubs
j'aime bien et ça s est dans plein de
contexte ça marche ça marche côté
vraiment énervé ça peut marcher dans un
moment coquin savent marcher ouais ça à
kerry watkins à toi avant quand j'ai
quand c'est une femme et je n'aime
vraiment pas ces tirelires parce que
creuse avec une fente
vous dites tirelire elbeuf oui et un mec
abbas à un pauvre con c'est trop de
tuchan fait seulement du sang fait pas
ça on connaisse à la mairie on le sait
bien risquer quoi vous comme insulte non
la vraie non non moi je suis entre entre
tarbes à j'aime bien tabac tard bah
ouais c'est vrai que vous ne le dites
souveraines souvent pour effacer mon
insultes proférées charzat voit chaque
fois alors agathe votre insulte
préférées non mais dites le plus sensuel
mensuellement
bah oui c'est assez sensuelle sa wii
sale connard
alors là ça le fait non regardez cette
caméra connard à là le mec qui va pas
s'arrêter à quand votre site préféré bon
ben moi j'ai été à l'école avec maxime
et donc quand je rentrais énervé gredins
très belle tête de l'udc tête de mon
artiste préféré
ce projet insulte aux siens mais par à
[Applaudissements]
coups de coeur et un vrai coup dur pour
le président pourrait mener le maquereau
très normé alors bon choix en parlant je
ne rêve avec le beauf ou non
pourquoi vous le savez et vous le savez
projets personnels
[Musique]